back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching
these selling me yeah by step I know I
listen to your member that team I listen
your solo podcast and now I'm just
trying to get through life onwards and
upwards
I've been down one step at a time one
step step by step day by day you
remember that trip if you even leave the
if you even walk past the studio over
there when the doors open you'll catch
ahead of it I know I got them dim
depression race I'm down dang man
where's my tail you turn in a straight A
or bro
you're broke and then be careful when a
Raiders Jersey now a dude and all these
cholos man okay am I here I was like oh
I [ __ ] up the hey pop am i quiet
throwing [ __ ] tamales at me like what
row like you would duck a tamale oh no I
can ask you bro I can only catch so many
dude yeah man
therefore when the Raiders Jersey in LA
man this thing was frosty shucks my boy
la jeune anywhere bro you could show bro
no joke you could be an astronaut land
off the quitter Raiders Jersey and a
couple of [ __ ] bangers are come out
on a straight-up a Joe alien come out
[Laughter]
first of all that's loyal Alzado r.i.p
bro one of the great dude he was it that
good but yeah for sure no but definitely
great alright it takes till it's awesome
some of those needles get big man I get
another 30 gauge needle project or the
shirt hey but keep talking about
steroids yeah he just stayed had a
[ __ ] Phillips screwdriver in his
[ __ ] back experience back in the 70s
man those those those needles were yeah
brother those things are huge
you can put yeah you could uh those
things were really really big did I
remember even being young um when I was
a child that needles were bigger than do
you remember that real big I should get
a tetanus shot in my ass one time
because the dog bit me in the booty yeah
this needles like bit him or I bet you
snuck over there put it in his mouth
[Laughter]
sneak a cheek into a Jack Russell bro
for reals this might happen
son of a I think I was in fourth grade
friends tree got struck by lightning
he's a guy he got a see it man so all
the kids like Oh sick so he go back
there and they pushed me and closed the
gate and I'm like I don't see no tree
struck by lightning and I see a
Rottweiler Oh bro
good thing I [ __ ] spider-man there
hey cuz he's going for my ding sound
like Brian right yeah city yeah they
could have killed the Rottweiler
yeah that's fourth-grade Rottweilers are
really honestly dude there's a black man
of dogs let's be honest bro dude I do
not mess around on our own that was a
dog when I was growing up dude that was
the most dangerous dog they had German
Shepherd got kind of wild and then
Rottweiler
Roddy's were the thing and they were
like a really wrap thing weren't they
like teach there's like t-shirts of them
with like chains someone turned in a
rottweil on that but didn't junkyards at
all did jyd have a Rottweiler ever with
him that came into the ring junkyard dog
oh I don't know I remember Rottweilers
growing up being like associated with
hip-hop oh yeah yeah well I remember
even to the nipples took over in the
area you would see like if I just
remember when I was young if black guys
had a dog or a lot of times it was a
Rottweiler was that real thing Derek
remotest making that up
no no hunter saying all my all my bigger
black the bigger the black I have a
bigger the Rottweiler yeah every time a
tie-pin
Rottweiler hip-hop but I can understand
that if you look at a Rottweiler it
looks like the baddest ass dog white
people had spuds Mackenzie which was
that I don't know if we can bring up
spuds Mackenzie you know the target dog
he's always partying all the time he's
drinking beer and [ __ ] yes pasta waves
this hall high white people I think if
it's struggling overall is just because
the dog that they chose even years ago
shows if you just get an image of the
dog his nose looks like mine looking
whatever be yeah what is he doing his
party use the party dog he has an iPad
wow that was targets main thing for me
when I was growing up that was a big mom
would get a spuds Mackenzie stuff all
the time
yeah me too man yeah this stuff spud me
Ken he was a national hit him and the
Dominos guy
Mir the red Domino's guy he made a video
game of them Domino's pizza guy oh the
no I know I know I wore the shirt do not
touch me I'd keep touching me just say
keep touching on the back a new shirt
Wow that's how cheap we are guys right
there to inside perfect example about
chief we are you want to look at the
back bro oh then you'll see what it says
on the back right at yourself write it
yourself dude you know a says write it
yourself dude we just assume you know
what's up well it's like I saw a
homeless dude earlier shirtless had
wrote in 24 for Kobe Bryant on his chest
and spray-painted on his chest a drove
way out of my way to go around him yeah
that's right the noid man he was a big
deal you know boy no way remember him
was there a video game yeah I had on
Nintendo but we're gonna be honest what
really happened for you Brendan was uh
it was a puppet show that your folks did
for you know there it is there it is
look that's a cover on the far left
that's it right there
and you'd bounce around the city you
know no it's not a racial slur I feel
like it is man yeah I think so you got
rid of it had something to do with their
pepperoni pizza
yo no wait no wait these noise are you
annoyed oh yeah oh you a little know it
oh yeah yeah
not annoy yeah like somebody from Norway
yeah no look at these noise out here
with their skis annoying man to grow
with their earmuffs yeah any guy that's
got to touch something furry on his head
to hear you yeah now I'm out bro
you have annoyed bro that's are you hi
Derek you look unbelievably irrationally
hi today every time we've met ever his
eyes are always red never not been hi
I'm always like we I've been high since
college
every day every day up in smoke I wasn't
yeah oh you like can't you can't
functional should we can smoke yeah it's
my base start yeah I don't give a [ __ ]
I'm just saying you're always high even
even around me even on the road 24/7 wow
you have a problem no this dudes are
here piss and molasses [ __ ] dry
outside over here you gotta [ __ ] put
some water to set his feet in Emily's
here man you got to start at the root
bro you got a hydro right I just stay on
coffee dude dude I just saw your tattoos
walk off your damn diesel you wake up
and smoke wake up and smoke you can't
fit what you've always been like that
Broadbent yeah F since probably at 2010
I'm in high every day ten years yeah and
is your whole family smoked marijuana do
no it's just me a while does your girl
smoke - girl smokes yeah did she smoke
before she may yeah she was already
smoking so many or did you get her kick
and no I didn't told you I didn't get
her kick and she probably did smoke as
much right as much wow
smile you're like a Puerto Rican Joe
Rogan yeah just smoking all the time
yeah he's sober October bro no you need
water wow you don't water never I don't
trust it dude drink according your hair
you drink olive oil
[Laughter]
accordin you're here you drink Sleepless
in Seattle so big ride Doug I hope
emails [ __ ] Dyke all stop why is it
like all something on here dude yeah why
can't we get him on here I don't know
how about roast mice CTE yeah how does
CT not have a gameshow dude why can't I
be the host of roast my CTE dude it's
like a burning should have a board game
yeah and it's it starts off kind of like
a Candyland and just dead ends and a
horrible [ __ ] game of scratch oh dude
no dude it's like monopoly all right
maybe it's a certain CT and I'm Park
Place baby
oh you're Baltic Avenue Perkis safe dude
rape my CT what a great game Tommy
central what's up bro robbing ideas
what's up comments missiles going out of
business they just let go of everybody
over there man they're basically they're
barely gonna happen then I'm barely a
nap well well get into it dude wait dude
you're uh you're gonna Hawaii are you in
Vegas this week in Vegas this weekend
I'm in Las Vegas whereas he's teaming up
being Mirage
oh okay oh you don't sit with the Blue
Man Group oh no oh where they're great
luzina get in there god they're gonna
shut the [ __ ] up about the blue yo
they're amazing take your kids everybody
Blue Man Group miss Lily not you know
they don't pay me I just think she's
that a racial thing like you got it's
like you guys hadn't associate with that
kind of thing or is there something that
I don't know about know everybody we
were the only black family there but
really up for the Blue Man Group
they perform oh yeah
re man isn't probably calling me oh oh
but did something just happen guys that
is like oh I gotta fell asleep or
something so your new Vegas yeah that's
what we're talking about your new Vegas
yeah have you guys never been I'm
feeling well nice would you go would you
see there I remember when they had that
big pirate ship kind of hotel in
Treasure Island yeah they're still there
dog was awesome you went when he went it
was a real ship it was like oh it's so
easy here's the thing my parents don't
realize if you if you kiss your kids hi
it's so easy to take them on vacation
anywhere taking with chuck-e-cheese help
it's like a circus circus yeah take him
to the cheese section of the grocery
store have a blast
take me of the cheese factory tow it's
Italy do dice have this dream where I
was running this dirty business where I
was taking blind people to UM Antarctica
or Iceland or something yeah but really
it was just a regular place and I had
people put ice all over the ground in
walls and then when they got there they
thought they were in like an exotic
country by dreams I'm a lot my dream do
you mean before you start sellin tickets
on the road no this a bad dream and I
didn't run the ship so crazy last two
thousand blind people on a cruise ship
and I was the captain every time I'd
have this dream of like we don't work a
whole shift like an eight-hour shift as
the cab it was horrible dude last time I
was in Vegas I was doing show at the
Orleans
mm-hmm and they went let me bring it I
was gonna bring Derek and like oh no we
got the old boot
we have to open our sky jimmies we don't
count me for about 70 years I'm like all
right whatever I guess I get this a 77
years go dynomite
Jimmy Walker Jimmy Walker holy Sh he was
like rich let the comedies I know
exactly you I've seen every episode of
the show name that I can't even remember
Albert Ernst yeah what do you mean
Janet Jackson was in goodness I don't
know I'm not familiar the show I know
you had a dynamite thing anyway so he
had the dynamite thing but he'd they
never he never really got any residuals
from that man these men worked at a time
you want to talk about Hollywood [ __ ]
people they worked at a time when these
I mean you know I don't think he sees
residuals from this yeah still hosting
that's just still airs places do you
like 300 mom you go to uh you know
Africa just got it there waiting for
Spain Jew but he got away man yeah
places like that it's so still airs
brother yeah I don't know what his
contract is with the show and [ __ ] all I
know is uh he was one of a kind one of a
kind he wants so he walked I'm waiting
I'm waiting to gone stayed you walk so
because he won't look me in the eye
he's like looking off like this and I go
meet Jimmy like what's up man I don't
I'm not familiar with him at all I just
know he's this older dude open for me
like this is a terrible idea for my god
in walks up goes I've been doing this
over 50 years I know everybody never
heard of you and just stay doing all
right man well have a good show up here
I don't know what you want me to do man
I'm dynomite yeah I don't know it was so
awkward damn anyone out there bombed and
then I roasted them well I want to stay
Oh does he you sell CDs you some CDs
yeah oh and make sure you get your CDs
from Jimmy Walker everybody wanna sign
your eight by ten out the what that's
what you want to do what the [ __ ] is a
legend bro dude how about like having
freaking Frederick Douglass's son
Frederick Douglas jr. perform for you
brother
and with you and you treat them like
that it's like yeah I don't know dude
it's like Charlie Chaplin has a legend
sure he's a legend for sure
yeah great guy so then when we're going
out there you know when they call my
name I'm going out there I go hey good
set brother
don't touch me don't touch me that's why
I was like oh cool man all right check
this out dude you want slang DVDs inside
eight-by-tens check this out I know my
Orleans out but its Orleans no it's not
dude I wasn't at that fancy yeah the
further you get from Vegas of the same
thing start losing letters you know it's
crazy yeah you're at the Mirage you're
at the Mirage you're at the IRA next
exit yeah you plant you're planning to
go to Hawaii though you're saying yeah
March I made maybe even go to Maui do
some shows over there
so some shows and chill out or what yeah
do some shows chill out it's nice over
there who takes more vacations you or
teachers I mean you take more vacations
anybody I know
I'm just I'm like you need a break oh
yeah dude I definitely need a break man
just surround a budget racism out here
man when you're selling stuff online you
know uh the orders can be a real pain
Brendan dude when you're selling stuff
online it's the dark web out there dude
you how do you know it's gonna get there
on time what are you gonna do it's just
such a hassle oh I bought a thing of a
summer sausage and a bunch of um like a
little kind of sweater showed of how
about cheese and then just sent me a
bunch of kids shoes yeah maybe I don't
know dude thank God for shipstation and
fastest easiest the most affordable way
to manage and ship your orders just a
few clicks and you're managing your
orders printing out labels getting your
product out as fast as you can be so
your customers are happy shipstation
makes it easy well it's just sad that we
live in this day now where the US Postal
System has gone to shi t so we got to
really spruce it up now and that's
what I'm saying with shipstation is you
can use USPS you can use FedEx UPS even
Amazon Fulfillment you can check out all
of the different options but you got to
take that extra step if you were gonna
get something where it needs to be on
time you'll be a big boy about shipping
man no wonder ship station is the number
one choice of online sellers just ship
more in less time with the best rates
possible grew up in right now King in
the sting listeners can try sip station
for viewers or viewers you can try chip
station for free for 60 days when you
use offer kaes and there's no risk so if
you think there's risk there's not you
can start your free trial without even
entering your credit card info saying
just visit ship station calm clicking
the microphone at the top of the
homepage
typing K 80s that ship station calm then
enter the code K 80s ship station calm
make ship happen and you know what you
did I saw you sipping oh I thought he's
ready to go I'm feeling look good dude
you look like Captain Planet after you
drink that stuff
oh man I feel like somebody just drugged
me through a garden with my mouth open
man I feel like a summer breeze brah oh
thanks I think that's good dude don't
one thing health experts dieticians
athletes and top performers all agree on
is that a perfect diet doesn't exist man
you need some help you need some help
you need someone to help you cover your
nutritional bases you can't do it
through food alone so ding ding ding
athletic greens come on down yep you
need that full body header athletic
greens includes prebiotics probiotics
probiotics mental make your hair look
nice enzymes all-in-one athletic drink
dude 75 ingredients to make you feel
right 75 vitamins not ingredients
vitamins bro it's your one-stop shop to
help support your body's nutritional
needs across five critical areas of
health energy immunity gut health
hormone neural and healthy aging bro I
try to sniff it the other day because
I'm so hungry I'm not the way to go
it burns put it in water still helps I
bet you I felt pretty good I'm gonna get
my nose I'm breathing just fine yeah
dude start your day the right way by
squaring away your nutritional needs
with athletic greens yep I love the
containers that it comes in I loved it a
little the the scoop this stuff is so
fresh it just feel good man yeah I just
feel good it's poignant man whether
you're taking steps toward a healthier
lifestyle or you're an athlete whatever
athletic greens takes the guesswork out
of everyday good health so jump over to
athletic greens com /k ATS and use our
special offer today for 20 free travel
packs valued at $79 with your first
purchase that's athletic greens dot-com
/k ATS you have support the podcast guys
we could use the help
putting greens comm slash cats should we
start a new segment yeah let's do it man
let's move along that sounds like a good
idea
race my case you want to do it oh let's
do it want to do it via racism yes let's
make a show out of it so for this
segment we research some odd crimes and
we're just gonna give you the
description of the crime and like the
headlines and you guys are just gonna
have to talk it out and guess don't
cheat chin chin cheating already and is
it is it current crimes or like don't
give me old [ __ ]
what do you mean their crimes what I
wish I did
no the only crimes happen in LA today
there won't be fun
yeah he's not a boy just do carjacking
so whole time if you think he's a cop
this is a great note for next time but
these are old okay I probably know you
probably know a lot of them did a couple
let's go all right number one police
arrested a 24 year old company employee
for smearing his own excrement on a girl
I feel like it is off immediately it
comes to wake up but I don't know a lot
of different kind of Orient traditions
from the Orient and that's where I want
to go to chin seems like he has intel on
this or I see him nodding his head
I just piggyback on this because I have
seen some interesting
porn in my day where I comes the [ __ ]
that Asians partaken what they call I'm
sorry
scat pains so it could be Asian or white
uh what is it called white for five
thousand out what scat babes oh you had
to make why do they do that you can't
just poop enough smell in Asia or
something just get really nasty there's
just they've done everything they want
to get as nasty as possible I've eaten
Japanese by the way okay Playboy so he's
going Japanese Chan's going Japanese
Derek wooden what do you have
yeah I'm gonna go ahead Korean because
if there was also a level of woman's
shaming and the guys rubbing only one
woman there's a level of I'm a man three
men hate women
yeah right if you guys need another
sentence let me know we have Noah
someone may have said the correct one
already but is there a quote no quote
but on December 5th at 9:45 p.m. blank
used a bicycle to come up from behind
the girl aged in her late teens at an
intersection why dude buy all of Asia
not America bro and this happened in
America I'm assuming dude can I get a
play sometime I'm not giving any
locations or names can you give me the
Greek meaning he's in a sentence blank
wit who is the dollar in Coaldale admits
to the allegations telling police that
the extra mint was indeed his own hell
yeah that's a white dude being like [ __ ]
you [ __ ] I don't know I feel like a
white guy would use somebody else's [ __ ]
you know that's all we do is take other
people's [ __ ] yeah there you go
so I think we would use somebody else's
dung or whatever they call a fee see to
pull off the crime now if there's a
white guy using other people's [ __ ] he'd
be in like a FUBU Jersey and listen to
hip hopper this just the dude straight
up white dude [ __ ] upset
Mike I'm cheating on them quick [ __ ] so
much sorry dude so a Brandon's final
answer is white the oni-san I'm gonna go
we need specification okay just Asia I'm
gonna go uh I'm gonna go Koreans the
dark Japanese and we do know we're
conflating a little bit nationality
and race but it makes the game better
the answer is what did we lock it
oh oh so good catch I'm gonna say white
dude cuz Asians will only do that if
it's consensual and Asians only do that
if they have an erection that's on the
side I feel like when first 48 we're
true detectives what do you got Nick
Derrick what was your final I want three
word word
the answer is Asian / Japanese it did
happen in Japan God oh that makes so
much sense that makes so much my big
summer sensei they do play with the [ __ ]
they do play with the [ __ ] dude quit
saying it so much all right they do play
with the feces thank you go man Asians
in their own country play by a whole
different set of rules
apparently then boys then boys are
freaky they take it over the top
I've seen some awful stuff yeah ii-i've
never seen any of that you don't want to
brother I don't want to and that's why
I'll take it into my life if you want to
ruin your date scat babes no college
dude sorry
yeah a lot of time on our hands someone
brought it no there's a lot of time on
their hands in college people who aren't
doing well at college we're playing
football and watch ask a baby
and winning football games all right
what else yet number-two man arrested
for allegedly allegedly throwing a
three-foot live alligator into a Wendy's
drive-through window this was this was
it was this juvenile who did this the
rapper
this sounds like specifically one of the
big timers would know he was 23 okay
okay this is America could be am i right
Nick I can't ask that do we well what do
we do we get a me yeah if you need more
sentences he pulled the 20-year old
had pulled up to grab his order and a
server handed him a drink when the order
when the worker turned around the man
allegedly reached into the back of his
truck and threw the alligator through
the open window
now hold on no you said truck okay
alligator check the the the soft drink
we speak of you just kind of blink if
I'm on to something
was it a sprite do they say what kind
they do not diet coke this is white boy
all day sprite
he's through a [ __ ] yeah ball into
them yeah if it was double great orange
soda Brendan I'm gonna go for me he
reaches in the back of a truck hasn't it
happens to have an alligator back there
this sounds very white or Vietnamese to
me yeah this is white as it gets truck
alligators I'm going honky on this one
they do honk honk all day do you know
what the fast-food is Wendy's
that's everybody loves one day's you
know dude there check the nice burger
the fries nuts the spicy Nuggets get
that 10-piece barbecue sauce you know
you get a frosty square burgers all day
chicken sandwich okay comater
they have one in Santa Monica oh yeah
Wendy's yeah a lot of people and over
there on 7th and uh at Santa Monica
Boulevard
everybody loves Wendy so except that
doesn't help you use in a sentence again
was the employee black or white or Asian
or do we know what the employee race was
we didn't get details on the victim any
JPEGs okay good call all right I'm
locking in man I'm going white how big
was the alligator three feet yeah you
could tie that around your foot and say
it's a shoot I don't know why this is
news something he's given my gift
buddy stoked if something a [ __ ]
alligator oh thanks dude razor as well
well that's a churro in Vietnam
but alligator gang [ __ ] I'm gonna go
white all day I'm white white white
white dude from Florida mmm
why dude cat with the bonus point he was
Floridian white man like a little [ __ ]
chin you'd even guess Wow yeah I don't
participate your own life that's good
much a life pass by chin okay yeah so
cat gets that bonus point man dude all
right give us one more time last one man
urinates in Walmart as he puts trout in
his pants oh yeah man was arrested after
a urinated Walmart we're trying to put a
package of trout in his trousers and
then told police officer that he wasn't
concerned because his crimes were only
misdemeanors
there's nothing wider than trout it was
1:30 on a Wednesday what there in the
afternoon I faking you it's the city in
this one it's Walmart yes do we do we
want to give the city I can't give the
city if we need more might as well you
want the city to city of what we're this
walled city of God Brazil you also said
he'd he was uh had been consuming
alcohol mm-hmm and what he's hiding
trout he's hiding a package trout so
frozen trout these are not live trout
who that would make me yearn and I think
is frozen trout straight to your Weiner
area for a couple trout he's near my
pelvis and try to pretend like you
didn't that's the hard part then that's
where you shock your nervous system in a
urinating but stealing Troutman it's
cheap yeah yeah things are rough dude he
knew was the misdemeanor so he knows
he's been through this he's been through
the system before yeah this just sounds
like somebody who's just out there you
know like they just happened to pick up
anything it happened to be trowel black
no white lie buddy he knows the system
too well to misdemeanor it's only maybe
somebody just like salmon
that droughts cheapest [ __ ] you know
like maybe he's trying to go to jail
like maybe he's trying to maybe he knows
if he gets caught it's like doing you
know and it's tip for stealing [ __ ]
crab can't take away your right to vote
for a misdemeanor right yeah there you
go I'll go black I'll go black as well
just because I've already done some of
the other
I can only say white so many times I
think I use him again yeah yeah I think
it's no great Chinese Walmart so if I
don't Nick it's not a black guy another
Korean I just I would if I here's the
thing if I had to watch somebody do it
honestly I'd like to watch a black guy
do it I think that's why honestly
because they would do it in the most fun
way agree you know this man was from
Clarksville Tennessee and he was black
wow that's a cold case the coldest case
is frozen cold cold case baby I did
think about as a [ __ ] it's doing three
white people yes be hilarious and I
probably get them all right but it's
good to know that everybody's doing
crime and it's good to know that uh
that's the important part
yeah he's doing race my case - who won I
think I think cat took that bonus point
I voted the Florida one yeah like I said
I think that's more of a gif costing
someone a three foot alligator mm-hmm
it's a lot of smart Billy but when
you're at work I think give it to when
they leave a word yeah you know yeah you
know to drive through orders and
somebody [ __ ] throws a new pet at you
that sounds drastic all right dude let's
get this bus on the highway what do we
have going on today son fun game though
guys race my case if you guys have a
couple can they submit them uh yeah I
would love that if you submit them just
include all the information as many
details as possible and definitely try
to specify highlight the race so
that's one that's fun yeah there's a lot
of fun crime crime has no happens man
crime has no color it's true I think
that's what we learned guys what do
nothing all right dude manscape sent me
their new stuff
send me the third-generation manscape
trimmer Oh haven't opened it yet it
looked pretty pretty frosty and I didn't
know is just for you knew you're nuts
I'm put on my face did you still work
there dude it's still okay Razor Ramon
Road is your fate your cheeks are
getting real hard when a woman walks by
though a little weird look
I've been talking about manscape for a
while now man I use it I love the tremor
that I still have the 2.0 but I love the
tremor that they have man the lawnmower
dude you haven't started living till you
get that lawnmower 3.0 dude it's
available right now right now dude well
I just know the stuff that I have is
keeping my junk nice and also when I
start to notice for myself you know I
get these beautiful kind of swaths of
hair Billy did go me dude I use it there
I get this thigh burns you know I get
real I kind of have side burns on my hip
yeah I get some like like chops like you
almost get like some side burns in the
inside my legs I get them James Dean's
going down the middle of my thighs here
so I get trim those up too yeah you
should sounds hot in your pants brother
I'll bet your pants come off easy with
all the sweat you got going on a Russian
look if you're listening to me speak
right now you're one of the first people
to hear about this life-changing product
from manscaped they've upgraded to a
7000 RPM motor with quiet stroke
technology now I'll say this I've been
using quiet stroke technology for a
decades cuz I used to have to stay over
at my grandparents house when I was
about 16
also 7000rpm motor - I might use it for
my freaking by boat as well dude get
around
you're nuts you don't tell oh yeah dude
bro you could do barnacle a battleship
with that bad motor scooter to 7000 rpm
sighs look problem you'll never look the
same Robin Williams Allan Jumanji just
[ __ ] nuts are gonna look like a like
an old board game here's what I'm saying
get 20% off and free shipping with the
code Kay 80s at manscaped
dot-com get 20% off and free shipping
with code Kay 80s at manscape comm use
code Katz manscape calm your balls will
thank ya yes we got one take it old
school of debate club yeah let's do it
tally we don't a Leo what's tally like a
racial slur no tallies from South Park
the Tau highest [ __ ] he's always ha oh
I've heard that I haven't seen the a of
the animal but you ever seen tally oh hi
uh uh thanks Adam Derek looks a little
like tally tally he looks a little like
me he said Derek why do you look like a
1988 Oprah Italian slice you know you
know there is I could see Italy always
getting high I could see it a little
miracles like eyes of Stewie though yeah
yeah from Family Guy I think that's a
compliment
yeah tallies a compliment that was
companies funny all right let's do it up
first we got Danny from Brownsville
Texas Brownsville one ticket to
Brownsville
huh any time about your high school what
Brownsville one of my friends grandma
live in brownsville on the border
actually she died she passed away still
she did live there is this Texas yes
this Texas where we go get possibly we
going yes we must [ __ ] hey yo hey yo
what a Brandon what a deal love the
[ __ ] podcast I got a debate club for
you and uh perfect well as the better
movies Al Pacino
Robert De Niro both legends both are
classics but who has the best collection
of movies it's when the gang signs gang
[ __ ] your Spanish on point
buzz buzz gang gang you walled Papageno
Widow thank you thank you very much
our amigo where we appreciate you
sending this in from there from
Brownsville from the border bro y'all
hold it down over there oh yeah that's a
good question I'm going to Nero man
that's Al Pacino what you know then yeah
the Nero got to political for me I'm
going Pacino here's the other problem
with Robert De Niro he was [ __ ]
crushing it when he was younger and then
all of a sudden he it's this girlfriend
right and she wants all this [ __ ] so
then he has to keep making these shitty
movies so hit he started towards the end
of his career started making [ __ ] movies
dude being the dad of the grandpa and
everything you know I'm saying yeah dude
the Irishman is pretty I mean it's like
it's bad it's almost like a book well my
problem is they look like avatars like
the the the makeup dude just hire young
actors yeah just how are you yeah I like
the digital [ __ ] well it's just like now
some of these movies and I do respond
it's like when somebody gets into their
prime it's like they almost make a movie
we just get to look at them for two
hours you know look at him for three
hours yeah dude that was so good
I'll go Pacino who was in taxi driver
that was Pacino house the Nero De Niro
Wow
raging raging bull' De Niro keep De Niro
and Al Pacino meet the parents
Goodfellas Robert De Niro Casino Robert
De Niro hmm
makes it real tough and what some Pacino
ones
I found me AK out of all the movie star
fathers guard hot father's allowed
Carlito's Way Oh Serpico was called
surfer girl you know where's the cop
yeah i'ma stay uh-uh I love that movie
with the Bob who just a pervert dude
some blonde yeah I'm wandering around
do I like Al Pacino in Jack and Jill
with Adam Sandler - I like that movie -
yeah Robert Dino's a [ __ ]
he's a mom yeah I mean look there's a
lot of great options out there
Godfather's oh those were so great he
well they're both in I know yeah what
are some other movies Robert didn't
Robert there's some big boys though
casino Goodfellas Goodfellas the intern
I'm just naming all this he's got some
rough ones he had some rubbers nothing
babe pig in the city he was he was the
city was it he was the fish and shark
still he was a fish a shark so he did
the comedian yeah oh he's a joker bro oh
yeah blast in the face spoiler alert
let move he's been out for so long I
need dirty grandpa
mmm I've been in some downhill buddy
grandpa oh he's on Saturday Night Live
three times dirty grandpa tough that's
an L the intern grudge match like I said
he made some real for you get Vegas dude
he made some [ __ ] movies and he got
caught yelling at his girlfriend in a
restaurant because of it okay just like
to make those [ __ ] movies that's what he
said yeah and he only dates black girls
you know that oh yeah a point for Robert
didn't it yes not know that we likes the
black hair like I'm Kate that's a huge
point I'm with them 15 minutes men of
honor
okay let's get
over to Al Pacino then man this is too
many movies this guy's done you can't be
good if he does that man you super
political though too right it's all
political it'll weird now I liked when
he touched on see older please like I
would like that older people get
political they always do well there's
nothing else to do is this
now Pacino is definitely held up better
I think dude Dick Tracy Wow oh dude hold
on dude Willie Beamen
you're gonna go out to every inch we've
raided by that in Levi garnet oh my god
what was that
do memory loss any given Sunday Latika
oh we've all time what's once upon a
time in Hollywood you didn't like it
like it what was it it's kind of I guess
a documentary of Charles Manson
narrated by tina.bill worst
oh I loved it Ocean's thirteen he was
after 13 just good my hair like that one
uh for the money Angels in America G Lee
oh yeah that's a knock against any given
Sunday due to for the money
devil Chinese coffee he was in some bad
[ __ ] Donnie Brasco color you know with
Al Pacino for the win
are you you know what I'm a very rich
scent of a woman really did it for me
man do I wish we could play that we
fight for that inch
yeah did we get them on the run we're
gonna keep on the run gonna go go go go
go go go
we're not gonna stop I'm gonna stop
Ricky going dr. Rudi we're across that
goal line they don't keep going to
getting across the goal and I was
traveling around the city with the ball
Rudy's offsides I stand by that what
else 63% DeNiro Wow that's alright a lot
of people want to get Ailes today there
you go boy here's a plate of Ailes for
all y'all is our boy Jamie from the
United Kingdom hey mate then I want what
a Brendon what a view
can't Derrick Jin first and foremost me
but you guys make me smile a lot and I
need it right now so bigger gallon my
name is Jamie I'm from the UK as six
brothers Sheffield Sun representing up
some little women at the moment and I
got at the big club for you what's
scarier spiders or snakes we don't get
snakes here so it's easy to choose but I
have the impression that here was
wrestled a Python a - to the ground
yeah and it's but I know that Brendan
wrestled a snake or - do you catch my
drift beat you to the joke obey this
make wrestler still fighting over an
English I fighting some Cobras in my
mouth Brendan Britney going nine rounds
with a meat garter oh this milk snake
well I gotta melt this snake this
doesn't have lot of milk in it good day
brother I'm a huge Charles Dickens fan
brought shout out Britain yeah shout out
England brush out the UK Sun shadow -
Jack the Ripper yeah yeah who else
the gentleman shot - the family jewels
the gentlemen shout out - uh I got the
Christie I think was British shout to
the prince who was just like no I don't
want to do this anymore I moved to
Canada that duck out friend [ __ ] you
think he was really sick of it II think
yeah he kept saying I need a vacation
sounds like you you kept saying he needs
a vacation all the [ __ ] time it just
moved to camera yeah dude I would love
to do I Canada's great man that is great
hey move there Oh bro separately cold
I've moved Vancouver but the colds don't
mean colds almost done because of the
Playmobil warm yeah I mean or just
global - angel what rule will change it
I mean look here's the thing
educate the people you can't have went
everybody don't get winter forever
so how's shag never summer yeah so
something at some point Alaska's gonna
get the summer
and Florida's gonna get the winter
that's the circle of life
amen so I know some people are pissed at
it because they have beachfront property
that's only gonna be able to be used for
ice skating in about 15 years
Oh laughs is house half full of course
I'm saying where the the angst comes um
scarier spiders or snakes dude listen
any spider any [ __ ] spider I can
crush my [ __ ] foot a snakey snakey
I'm [ __ ] I'm not scared of a lot of
things I'm scared of snakes bro I'm
[ __ ] scared of snakes it's obvious
you spent some time with some man if you
refer to it
snakes do that I had once my mouse you
were there Oh guys came over I became
his [ __ ] luggage yeah came over to
play basketball dude look at this snake
and use your trike all right so look at
this spider and you try killing I didn't
grab my shoes the biggest thing I've
ever seen really I swear on my life he's
[ __ ] this fat dude I took a picture
of it people understand told me yeah
there's one there though oh there's a
spider I think in Australia eating a
little piece of muffin you can see it
almost grabbing muffin yeah can you
google that spider with muffin do you
like have you seen that spider eats fit
like grabs fish there's a video a spy
like grabbing [ __ ] like a cute like and
then throws a peace sign and goes and
goes back in the cake and then he puts
back on his beats headphones and walks
back yeah eats muffin maybe spider
eating muffs
spider muffins yeah probably gonna work
as a D get less high huh watering we can
it Suzy's cupcakes right now we'd say
order 12 of them dude Derek so many
everything he brings up is just
postmates
trying to use the coat ATS
look at that spider-man the amazing
peacock spider it has both of its arms
up in the air like bring it in never Sam
dude this thing looks like frickin uh
who's that guy that shot himself in the
hand for the Giants
Plaxico oh no that was leg John Paul
Jones Oh John drum cow no no useful uh
he's holding a firecracker Larry here
Paul yeah he tried armwrestling an m-80
Jason pierre-paul Jason yeah I tried
armor so now maybe and blues [ __ ]
hands off now he's like this and they
had a bad season like we're all sad bro
because of my hand I went call what you
want okay let him go haha yeah he went
down to Tampa
oh yeah friends shouldn't play with
fireworks you know you're right bro um
okay I'm sure you've had some this in
New Orleans there's some [ __ ] bro oh
there's some definitely some writers got
the manic ondas down there that's all
JLo that's a movie the thing I don't
like the most down in the south is a lot
of frogs will hide in like the door in
between the doors I celebrate and uh
like the top of the doorframe
you know so you open your door in the
morning in a frog will fall I just don't
like that surprise ass frog yeah and
they're wet always well ways with the
snakes
um spiders spiders coming at you at
night we had some ladies stay with us
when we were young and a roach crawled
in her head and she had to go to the
emergency room and get it cut out yeah
we heard of those pickets usually hate
to be shitty huh it's usually Asians
we're spiders calling their ears like
lay eggs and have to get it out but for
them it's like spies in that fashion
over there
I think the Asians are always doing
something so it might be some sort of
ramen broth that they're trying to get
out of there like oh there's a baby bird
in my ear right now yeah what's that in
your a year oh it's a family of four
yeah they're sparrows these snakes all
day rattlesnake being from Denver
Brattle snake ask your boy Mike stud
well they go let me [ __ ] rap and run
across Colorado
snap today [ __ ] rattlesnake in the
posner got hit when I say mykes
yeah like so that's a gay porn star it
would be a great point so I named Mike
stud he's a white rapper too busy
yeah he's dope all right now yeah he's
my boy uh yeah my ass Mike poisoner
Posner about your [ __ ] rattlesnakes
yeah he got a little baby one oh there's
Mike sterling in hot he looks a little
bit like in that one picture and the
blue shirt here's some dope hits man he
looks like a little bit like yeah right
there okay who's that kid that kid they
got took in Colorado that little girl
JonBenet Oh cuz his blue eyes hear the
baby blues he got that jean monnet face
good Oakland booty
he was datin Jose Canseco's girl was he
dude how about he was up he was a
baseball player at Duke he's a pitcher
and got injured so he just [ __ ] he all
this time after that surgery
so he'd rap in the locker room all the
time and then the his boys the team it's
like dude not bad dude so he's like do
let's film it I liked it we'll do a
party and I'll rap and you guys film it
he upload to YouTube good friend he's
killing it you know hard especially dude
that's brave were to just do that in
Allah if you've been an athlete to then
try and wrap that's brave bro no he's
the man dude he's he signed with a post
Malone he did yeah here's some [ __ ]
hits man I used to check it for my
special yeah yeah mic stud son
Mike Posner went to Duke to
coincidentally here then Blue Devils
dude and Blue Devils dropping them hot
ass beats what else you got shoutout to
white rap shouts a Christian Laettner -
oh dude
54% snakes hell yeah yes but speaking of
white rappers though we got some more
there's nothing that makes me happy in
the white rappers riff there's not it's
so it's just good for you man mmm when
they tell you can't you can you know
yeah so you know our chance little
browse you guys remember a little brown
dollars caterpillar eyes he went hard
dude
so we got some contenders though oh yeah
we have some new ones got some new
trying to knock off the king of the
mountain yeah knock off brow brow
example brows again just once every
gonna be refreshed with [ __ ] with
that verbal gerbil hit on brow play the
last 20 seconds hidden brow huh King in
the sting Brendan and do fighter and
create a long relationship a CEO more
specifically Balder Brendan came in with
the chip on his shoulder but is stopped
by you're watching pizza drinking half
up here and kid like that Reza Rita I
saw cigarettes with a snapback on not to
hit the crib and staff chat on Hank is a
good we still mess with 1800 people
Boulevard Oh in the head Thursday a
blowout a minute late y'all wanna date
my fav Nick sent me that track I walk on
stage of that [ __ ] from now on hell yeah
tasty bro that puts me in a good mood
we're doing something right while you're
right calling the more a road rage which
is that cup is that D ball dark roast I
got us some Gold's Gym brother wood
straw with cream you got a back dude did
you get your blood work done yeah okay
say well they said there's a lot of
black in your blood they said they did
find a couple brothers in the stream
they said there's lot Lodi's although
with floaties
everybody okay no alarm here uh your
blood works fine there's a lot of
darkness you know I got some rays of
light that's supposed to be in there
they're like oh we just find a crying
Jordan in your blood like oh that's me
yeah that's mine that's one uh
no what did they say I have a call with
them today 3 p.m. to find out but
there's a company called uh oh I mean
this is a company that travels around
and they they'll come take your blood
they did it last week after we got done
I took my blood they're gonna tell me we
this week what's going on but they did
tell me that I got too much blood in me
so I gotta drain some blood how does
that happen they test this thing called
hemoglobin it's the one that looks like
a Halloween
sounds like a Halloween costume and they
test that when in a few have its high
then you have to drain some blood so I'm
giving blood away there you so you're
gonna give some blood and then are they
gonna put you onto the players put you
on some TRT they met people who know
some trt or some uppers or assad wazers
at least no Downers probably but uh
we'll see because also I don't know
who's get your blood I don't know some
ladies my I'm too sad all the time just
[ __ ] you somebody's like where's my tail
I got an accent on some reason I hate
this guy Brendan Schaub oh I just wanna
be mean to him all the time
oh I can easily tell you what it is dude
it's because you're like a [ __ ]
cannibal ate his whole family that's why
okay
kanima lurks around a Duncan Daniel
let's try we got on that JaMarcus
Russell Jersey he's from your [ __ ]
neck of the woods from LSU bro you threw
one deep ball some dumbass like number
one pick number one big but first of all
anybody fur coat yeah dude but the fur
was all I could it was in Chile really
died in a straight scissor remember he
was like 6 gallons deep on that sir
alright hit this white rapper who is he
they might ramble
[Music]
oh boy you be that fast is that hot rap
hot boys hot boys gang gang I'd do the
damn thing hanging this thing I'm
repping big brown a rat King the Obama
put the dawn foot the moonlit dawn every
single city he'd be looking for a single
mom yeah that's a trip and I'm a drip
like Derek raw doggin with his chick to
a Knick can't quit hate and get your
feet up for the pic had to make it
really quick but tell me what you think
so it up kid Gianni here mom [ __ ] twig
got peed a Billiken fourth oh quit
touching me but keep touching me bro yo
yo really nice in a team you're coming
in with that soft white heat hey that's
an easy listening yes baby jimmy stalker
bro yeah comfortable brother rolling
through your eardrums dawg that's not
white art Kelly [ __ ] yeah dude that's
that sex with only adults are Kelly sure
I wasn't mad at that
no I'm not mad at that at all day my
heart all right guys in this we have
another one what this is the contender
Tyler Dale oh [ __ ] Tyler Dale yeah Benny
God is and I'm talking cauliflower
muscle guy lips any type of horsepower
gotta give credit when credit dude hey
oh man I'm talking about you grown man
really fill them shoes Channel [ __ ]
seven leaving Clues gang hangs on the
news yeah if he reaches to the heavens
looking fo jokes
tell I'm better and you better tell you
folks used to do shows for five dollars
like a smokes now we making gold buzz
buzz all about the honey ten whips new
shoes any guy in honey hair slicked back
like it's always sunny gang gang spice
one love [ __ ] makes me wanna buy a 96
Mustang put the top down about to go to
enterprise run a Mustang Wow bro couple
cheaters bro I love that rat ah that rat
face they got on there too bro yeah is
that a wolf is that a rat that's a rat
baby that's the hardest right you ever
seen that's a wolf baby it's all good
though I know a rat when I see a rat son
yeah I don't know well you boys think so
you guys are picking one out of the
contenders and then the listeners will
vote like I've said this before I love a
full center here oh is that is it kind
of full it's real greasy man no it's so
thick dude I know put some product in
there really putting that in there do
you like I'm not going on a mullet so we
look like beavis and butt-head we look
like live-action beavis and butt-head I
can't do a mullet bro I wouldn't steal
your STIs like that hi Bobby Lee bro oh
yeah I really did like check out my hair
well dude now is that a typical Korean
thing to do from Bobby Lee for him to
sneak in and steal someone's stall as a
very Korean I
to say passed though he did so fast if
he just slowly did it it'd be one thing
but he did so fast that's not Korean you
do it slowly
okay Koreans do it slowly yeah because
you guys you guys took over pop music
like kpop I don't know where to slowly
okay pop is music dude it's a pretty
amazing tree and pop kpop check it out
dude
is it good kpop yeah it's super catchy
you'll love it who's the biggest one
what's her name BTS right now BTS oh
they're boys Ohan did they send in a
submission for King this thing and
they're Jews or not they're all Korean
it's tough to tell if it's men or women
the kpop they wear makeup
they're like good-looking people but you
can't it's tough I'm gonna watch them
yeah well BTS is fire dude they are oh
their track with Halsey Oh getting in
there like this BTS dude and their
beautiful young fellows huh oh yeah well
it's hard to tell dude we are beautiful
yeah that's why I'm saying good-looking
human beings mmm-hmm a handsome boys and
look at that on the Left who's that one
on the left he doesn't look very Korean
now here's the problem k-pop they make
these boys practise 23 hours a day out
of the 24 days you know and it's just
they just you can tell they hate their
lives Jackson 5 yeah yeah it's like
Jackson yeah it's like Michael Jackson's
dad's your manager what's all of them so
they're all dying inside and no one of
them are rich it's my crisis dad took on
money it's Michael Jackson's dad's band
yeah Wow your ins capo well I think good
lot so yeah good luck guys send in your
submission I'm a big fan we'll see how
it goes okay pop yeah yes in general if
you guys want to do have a kpop band
send us a submission no you freakin also
if there's actual kpop bands out there
amateur kpop bands for sure
you tell me you don't know any Chen not
personally they don't lie to us like you
lied too [ __ ] hot car yeah you did
let's bring that up right now we're
going to talk about
let's bring up I don't want to do it but
I've just hit me bang gang no buzz buzz
liar just so you guys know and then the
fans know - I literally we me and my
girl dated literally after Carla was
picked but it sounds like there was
something that happened on the episode
and let's bring out there was a comment
that somebody saw this image online of
me where you say an observation
observation you don't do chinnough
chinnough nen with where you said that
you were willing to go on another date
with Karl and then at the end you tell
us that you have a girlfriend
so which one once I'm out her tits yeah
and be down for another day dungeon that
Muppet with your wings yeah how about
that lo mein yeah boy our bed trying to
vein up in that lo mein boy yeah try to
get that egg roll in them noodles you
know me already a little Star Wars I
didn't mean to call you want on J yeah
and I was neither but I thought we'd
spin out foods either way edit that hey
no but you you sound like you were in
until we found out that she thought the
age was a issue and then kind of changed
your tongue no I was still all in and I
was gonna say that was gonna go on a
second date for I don't want anyone I
don't wanna let anyone down so I wanted
to keep it up you let us all down so
what you gonna have a family with her no
family at night and have little mixed
kids and let them down every night no we
wouldn't yeah we're gonna put a sword in
your heart in your father's yard change
a name Oh God
we would have ended it there cuz we're
not gonna go on a second date videotape
I saw it would end it there and then I
would've told you guys later I would've
told her to what you guys kept saying we
got to find another girl for chin or
something all that stuff was like no we
gotta end it right now I have to tell
you guys right now who's a company man
is that what you're saying
here's company my literally went through
all of it for you guys in the fans and I
literally started dating my girl after
the Carly thing after she was picked
I'm sure she'll selected either let you
guys down not go on the date or just do
it and have fun
but on the date it sounded like you were
trying to go after them juggles yeah a
little over the top when you say yeah a
little over the top
so were you act you're trying you're
trying to get some teriyaki on them kids
first am i right yeah right never but uh
let's hear I just want to know the truth
chin
hey what's what's your girl think about
all this chin she wasn't super stoked
about it but she understood yeah sure
she no sense of humor no she's not green
oh she's not huh
what is she Vietnamese Wow I love to say
again this is not me
it's not Kat it's not me I promise no
I've met I met the girl I don't remember
ICT by metro girl
this castle angle many times you didn't
know that Derek was with you in whatever
city you guys were in too easy no I do
you in San Jose do you happen let me up
so have you forgot but yeah yeah you
forgot again
welcome to below the belt
you know what CTC I'm like Daddy from
Fern Gully broke him oh wow yeah and he
killed himself after that role no not
the bat dude not the bat I thought was
hip issues sorry he had some bats in
this belfry man or IP Robin Williams so
your girl wasn't too happy chin I'd like
to make a video with her and see what
her thoughts yes we can we face tyrant
if she would like to send in a video and
let her know sand a little know her
honest thoughts because I feel a little
bit deceived and I'm not even know I had
to go through with it right but did it
seem you were live with him cat did it
seem like he was willing to escalate the
date to sensual levels if the honest cat
be honest no hold on let me let me ask
you that did you know he had a
girlfriend cat did he mention it at all
to you before yes I did know well salt
it was a cold case that kind of [ __ ]
sheep cat wouldn't like I thought maybe
so cat G so he's on the up-and-up here
that was in on the like I'm hurt guys it
was after we picked Carly all right so
either I don't do it or just
do it and pretend in half I did have fun
though how did well I'm glad somebody
had would you have let it escalate to
sensual activities I couldn't that's why
I said why couldn't you even with a
school for two days
it's got the big jugs a month or so
right bro she had those Milka lanterns
bro no I'm freaking lats on the hillside
you're out of your mind bro [ __ ] just
fine just fine okay
are you guys still communicating or not
no you Texan I just texted her and there
we go for what huh huh it's all whoa
dude
that night just to make sure she got
home safe well we need to find someone
Derick break up with you girl hey Kat
single I don't catch the ones and it
gets creepy Winston little cat out there
into the world no we send cat on some
dark web date I don't want that yeah
that's true least Jing can defend
himself yeah that's true kind of you can
always pull that earring off of his ear
and pop somebody's zip with it all right
let's get through this episode man I'm
starting to get bored you guys got a pic
who you'd like between the veil and
Tyler its pearly white day we're Tyler
with the wolf rag they're both fantastic
and I appreciate the effort both no
losers I think a good tie bracket
tiebreaker is the original beat our
second guy vicious he made that as self
eating arm and I thought crystal beat
though was it that's a rape alarm again
let me say Emblem because the first
homeboy used the hot boys he's the hot
boys because juvenile P yeah fine which
is a fire today
really that's a shame he takes a little
long to get into it and also his
magician racking best
it's flows not good either I like it so
Nick's hatin no Nick doesn't like them
this might have loved the lyrics what
don't you like about him
this he's not the other guy do your work
I do the damn thing hanging this thing
I'm reppin big brown a rat King steel
bomb put the dog put the mullet on every
single city he'd be looking for a single
mom yeah that's a trip and I'm a drip
like Derek raw doggin wit his chair
I'm a rat chin and promote or Nick cat
quit hating get your feet up for the pic
had to make it really quick but tell me
what you think say what everybody I'm on
[ __ ] twenty all right Peter Billy come
forth oh quit touching me but keep
touching me bro yo yo he did that during
his hard give me the other one yeah we
were talking the logo threw me off
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's it it's hard I'm with your boy
vicious right there shot the white red
bank [ __ ] keep fighting the good fight
yeah see you guys in the future bro and
that fit boys well I was quick
well chin got exposed uh no wonder your
cold case
we're all keep saying cold case this
episode it needs a whole case going
prison 60 days in dude suit your days in
in the water you do king of sting and in
jail probably some good content for us
in there yeah I could see that I'd see
that well I'm taking my ass to Ohio dude
I'm in Columbus Friday Saturday are you
really yeah I am dude shoutout to my boy
Maurice Clarett maybe I'll come out
there and see you bro yeah maybe [ __ ] uh
I'm going to Las Vegas so I'll be there
Friday and Saturday and that's it that's
what's going on I got Oroville coming up
whoo that's a fun one
yeah I'm excited man I love that one and
send in all those video submissions we
need some relationship advice that I
forgot relationship advice people are
probably dying yeah well they need to
ask then I know men debate clubs King in
this thing it yes we have the
information you need any clown my hound
or Scheid my ride it's way better if you
use a video and tell us a little bit
about the animal don't just set in JPEGs
yeah sending in a dirty jpeg of a net
some guys mean also there's deceased
animals somebody's sitting in here
getting a little CD some of it yeah
girls are sitting in videos for
threesomes go stop in a while y'all
regular submissions just waking up and
bonging out and busting and the closest
thing to us every day okay so for our
last arm what is right doc
Oh smoke whoa smoke row went for you
over here sir smoke oh I think it easy
bro give me you gotta back off that bus
Larkin over here what if you quit weed I
bet you it look just like a son this is
your brain oh hey let me stop smoking
weed you look like genuine do those a
meetin woman [ __ ] wait Navin always
tryin to [ __ ] somebody Oh bro that was
the best song to put on here trying to
hook uh-oh dude dude you got that on
your apartment how so buddy you know the
Steve's who had a seven years old